all right we're gonna uh we'll get
started though i'll come over here um
obviously i'm very excited about doing
this uh before we get started um i don't
know where constantine is from reed
smith uh reed smith is uh sponsoring
this they're amazing keith and i don't
know really where we are in the store uh
but we're here this cool place and uh
reed smith's like an 1800 person law
firm they do everything from tech
they've got a huge crypto practice etc
uh i use them for a bunch of stuff
so take that for what it's worth either
i'm an idiot or they're good um but uh
if you are looking for any legal
services uh talk to constantine he's the
there he is right there
i was gonna say the good looking guy
uh but uh but go check them out so thank
you guys so much for uh for sponsoring
this
all right are you ready keith
you gotta turn it on i think
now i'm ready yeah see there we go one
meal that's the only time tonight that i
will look better than keith all right uh
what is your resting heart rate
uh it's 46 today which is lame why it
should be 44.
that's a great place to understand keith
or boy um
why is health diet berries all this like
like why do you spend so much time on it
and what has changed over the years
around your health or diet uh
in your life
so it's a function i mean truthfully
it's a function of vanity life extension
and performance and they're all related
like you can't disembank disinfigurate
these some things are then around like
how do you live longer
like have more life span so to speak
when you can be active
of getting old did you start thinking
that way
second thing is definitely aesthetics
like vanity like anybody else i just
like i'm conscious about it and the
third is pure athletic athletic
performance and competing with people
and competing for various things so for
example resting heart rate mostly around
life extension uh two minute recovery is
definitely around life extension um you
know other things are designed for other
purposes
berries just happens to be the most
efficient way to do it like so i'm
generally pretty busy in one hour i can
do everything i need for all three goals
and it's the only time probably during
the day that i put my phone away which
is a pretty big accomplishment maybe
date night i'm usually pretty good at
putting uh we do two day nights a week
i'm usually pretty good at putting my
phone away
so are you optimizing for longevity or
you're optimizing for all three of them
pretty much all three like for example
if you were optimizing only for lifespan
you'd probably never drink alcohol you
can debate this whether you should have
like a glass of red wine once in a while
but like i actually do drink alcohol so
obviously i'm not totally optimizing
that way
but like generally speaking optimizing
for
the middle of how do i live longest be
as high performance as possible like
mentally so i optimized my sleep we were
talking about mateo just briefly but
like i've been optimizing my sleep for
like 30 years like literally eight hours
sleep basically every day um and then
reverse engineer everything around that
so it's accommodation
so we're gonna talk about a bunch of
topics that uh some of them are very
down the fairway some of them will
people will be scratching their heads
being like what are these guys talking
about um but
part of why i want to start off talking
about fitness is there's a mental
clarity that comes with being fit with
eating healthy et cetera is there
anything that you do specifically for
the mental clarity or the ability to
think better make better decisions well
sleep is definitely the number one
variable if you're going to change
anything in your life if you change your
sleep you're both going to live longer
most likely but you will definitely
think smarter ox smarter have a better
personality i used to remember as an
executive at square i'd present you know
i'd actually run the board meetings at
square and i had this board member some
of you will know mary meeker was on my
board
and
she would observe after a couple of
years that she could tell how much sleep
i had the night before a board meeting
because my vocabulary would suddenly
shift and i would use like less elegant
words
and usually my usually before a board
meeting my adrenaline would be running
so my sleep was mediocre but the fact
that she could notice this and i
actually knew the sleep differences and
she was picking up on it it was just
evidence of how
you act differently when you haven't had
you know a perfect night's sleep
obviously there's great studies done by
the stanford basketball team about free
throw shooting and three-point shooting
that really make it clear that elite
trained athletes stanford basketball
team historically been pretty good so if
you can add 10 percentage points to free
throw percentage by sleeping an extra
hour that's like amazing you could train
for the rest of your life and not add 10
percentage points to your free throw
percentage or like similar comparable
percentages to threes so that that was
very eye-opening but i was already
pretty dedicated to sleep
so when we think about how to think
before we actually talk about specific
topics uh you're trained as a lawyer i
think you practiced for like maybe three
days no i was dumb enough to practice
for three and a half years okay my
friend peter thiel practiced for three
months and four days and he still
introduces me as this is my greatest
character flaw he's like literally he'll
be like oh keith's obviously incompetent
because it took him three years to
figure out what i figured out in three
months
true story actually he's done this
several times no doubt that's a true
story uh what did the legal training
though uh from a how to think standpoint
like what do you attribute that you took
away from it well
there's a way of thinking that you
learned as a lawyer and some of it's
very valuable across all disciplines
some of it's very narrow the the part
that you do develop a hierarchy of
thoughts in an organized mind one of the
ways you can tell is if you ever date
somebody who goes to law school you will
see his or her mind change before you
everybody who has who dates somebody
through law school notices the change in
like how their significant other starts
to think so that that's really useful
you do learn a little bit too much of
what they call issue spotting so when
you're graded in law school the the
primary driver of your law school exam
grade is how many of the potential
issues can you identify things that
could go wrong and then can you resolve
them meaning discuss how they would most
likely be resolved by a court of law
the problem with this so it's a very
good
uh general exercise like of avoiding
risks in life but it leads to a little
bit of overthinking because every
everywhere you go everything you see all
you do is these problems it's like
problems still left problems to the
right just like that song joker still
left you know uh so you start thinking
like everything that can go wrong which
really doesn't help you certainly not as
an entrepreneur or investor like when
people pitch me with an uh a new
investment idea it's obvious what can go
wrong the heart with our part is what
can go right
but so that part doesn't translate as
well and then the part that also
translates relatively well is you know
i've been involved in a lot of financial
services
heavily regulated areas with ip issues
or like health care with with lots of
legal issues and being trained as a
lawyer allows you to navigate stuff for
yourself is rather than outsourcing it
to some block box and so i like things
that have perceived legal and regulatory
risk because i don't outsource the
diligence to other people
so when you think about that pathway to
becoming an investor or an entrepreneur
are there certain operational roles or
certain investment styles that lend
itself if you have been trained as a
lawyer you're more likely to be better
at operations or marketing or a venture
investor or hedge fund investor like how
do you think about the overlap uh coming
into investing in business a global
statement is i always believe that you
should invest in things that you have an
asymmetric advantage in so the earlier
in your life you figure out what your
asymmetry is the easier it is to you
know sort of magnify that amplify double
down on it so if you're a lawyer for my
point i love things with legal risk like
maybe the most obvious example of this
is when youtube first uh was started
yeah i knew the founders from paypal
we'd worked together on paypal and i met
them at a barbecue or i met one of the
three ran into one of the three at a
barbecue and i asked him just casually
like hey what are you up to just like
you would do like sort of introduce
yourself to any friend at a barbecue and
he said oh i just launched this new
company
and it's like well what's it called then
it's called youtube.com i said okay what
does it do and he basically is like
sharing videos blah blah i asked him
three questions
um literally as we're lying to get a
drink like literally like in line to get
a drink at my friend's place and at the
end of those three questions i was like
i need to invest can i invest he's like
don't you want to see the website and at
the time this is like 2005 or six or
something we didn't have like you know
basically computers in our pockets and
so
he goes to the host guy named mike and
says hey can we borrow your computer and
so we go off into mike's bedroom and for
the next hour he shows me every single
video on youtube which was very painful
but it he did allow me to invest now the
point of the story though is
when people
when i started telling other people
about the potential opportunity to
invest with me because
back then i couldn't write a big enough
check myself to need other people
every single person talked to their
lawyer friends and every single fund was
like terrified of the legal risk and so
i just walked through
my favorite funds at the time the legal
diligence myself i just said here's what
people are going to tell you and here's
the right answer and blah blah blah and
you know not surprisingly we were able
to convince a very good fund to go
invest uh but like if i didn't
understand ip loss i happened to have
been partially an ip litigator there's
no way that i would have been able to do
that a with confidence and you know
enough credibility to convince a very
large vc fund but b
would i have known the right answer
myself almost surely not kind of funny
anecdote to this is there was one part
of the law that i forgot so you know i
graduated law school a long long time
ago and had quit a few years before this
there's a slight part of law around
music licensing that's that works very
differently than standard law and
certainly i.p law because congress
passed a statute in like 1914 or 1910 or
something where every time music plays
in the background there's a statutory
fee so it's one of the few things that
doesn't doesn't have a market price
and i sort of forgot this part
because it doesn't generally conform to
normal principles a lot
so when youtube did eventually have some
legal risk it was only because of the
background in music being played in the
background of the videos that caused a
problem they never had ip risk around
the actual videos which is what
everybody was paying attention to but i
sort of forgot that now we passed the
statue of limitations so i can tell the
story
what were the three questions that you
asked
is it coded in flash was the number one
one um there's a reason for that i'd
been waiting for three years to fight a
company uh i found it on flash so my
friend max why well so
after we left paypal
um i went to work sort of part time with
my friend peter thiel
and peter said go down to mountain view
and figure out the future and what he
meant is go talk to max max left him and
so it's like okay
so i called back so i'm like peter's
dispatched me down to mountain view to
meet with you to figure out the future
of technology i'm not just like okay
whatever so we sit down and he starts
you know he's like i can't really
predict the future but
he's like one thing that is kind of cool
is this thing called flash and
no idea i've heard of it but no idea why
so he explained to me that all the
magical properties in 2003 that flash
had and that someone would take
advantage of it particularly around
commerce but like here's what it could
do that other people weren't realizing
so i'd been looking around scouring the
universe to find some way to invest in
flash and then i realized as you're
talking about videos that flash was
actually a pretty good application about
second
question was around whether it was long
tail videos or he was targeting like
professional videos and he said long
tail videos which led to some of the
legal analysis but made me more
interested i always am interested in
long tail stop still i'm interested in
long tail stuff as the guys from open
store here no and then third the
question was and we had a well we had a
paypal product that internally
we called x x click for the web what
that really was was an html button you
can embed in your ebay listing and
that's what led to the viral adoption
of paypal back in the day
and so i said are you going to be able
to do something like xclick for the web
and he's like yeah that's the whole plan
so
fully embedded flash video that could be
embedded anywhere and it would lead to
ideally the same adoption as paypal and
it actually turned out to be the case
pull it back to the website uh you
mentioned paypal how much of it is like
nurture versus nature do you got the
right people into that business versus
you guys had some magic potion and got
everyone to be really smart and go on to
be super successful afterwards
i think it was mostly that peter and max
deserve a lot of credit for hiring
people so peter hired most of the
non-technical people max basically hired
all the technical people
and they assembled a critical density of
talent and then that became
self-fulfilling meaning the derivative
people that were hired were probably
comparable and you know you get a
critical density tell and all of a
sudden things that are unsolvable will
become solvable i don't think i mean
there was definitely lessons i learned
that i
specifically abstracted
from those days and those people but
fundamentally came down to their hiring
skills
last question about kind of history
paypal obviously is
now not only very well known that story
but everyone went on to do such great
things that i think a lot of not
everyone
there's 254 people there you know
probably about 20 games
20 people went on to do great things but
i think a lot of young founders look at
that they're like wow that was this like
amazing business um
on a scale of like you guys had your
[ __ ] together it was a complete [ __ ]
show internally where were you on that
scale it was a complete [ __ ] show
like well one easy example of that is we
had three ceos in four months
so you usually don't have three ceos in
four months unless things are going
pretty catastrophically wrong uh the you
know the other empirical data point is
in august 2000
we had
a burn rate of 10 million a month and 30
million dollars in the bank
in the in the middle of the complete
internet bubble collapse so that's a
real problem um but it was always kind
of a mess it was a kind of a fun chaotic
mess it was intentionally chaotic that
once things started working
peter came back as interim ceo after we
fired elon musk september 25th 2000
and within a couple months it was clear
that the you know first derivative
and second derivative were good or
better and then you know things did work
but it was always always a mess there'd
be like all these random things that you
thought everything was okay and then
boom you know gets slapped in the face
with some very pleasant surprise
so in november i was mindlessly
scrolling on twitter and i saw somebody
uh chirp at you and say are you calling
the top and you responded it was october
18th by the way and you said yes and i
said to myself they better hope to god
he's wrong because he'll never let them
forget so by the way it wasn't a random
person this is it was ari levy of cnbc
so it was a pretty well-known journalist
and i think it was the day of the top it
was exactly the day
it was off by a couple hours
so uh
they have not forgotten because they
keep bringing it up um describe why you
thought it was that and a lot of it i
think came from the 2000 uh kind of
bubble bursting and kind of what the
historical
overlay was so yeah i mean 2000 a lot of
people had this view including a lot of
my colleagues at founders fund that i've
been
let's say cracking a whip on recently
that things just go up into the right
and then it's only a question of time
like every company will be worth more
money or more value over time whether it
takes one year two years three years or
five years so that you could pay any
price for an investment let's say
because eventually you'll grow into that
and that's logic
over the last 18 months peter and i
particularly internally were like this
market is going to collapse here's why
blah blah blah so internally we've been
debating this
pretty consistently
with with incredible clarity both peter
and i argued this at an off site last
summer
and then strongly argued like about a
week before so one of the reasons why
we're already asked we had done we
conducted an offsite in san francisco
about a week or two before and i'd made
strong case internally that we should
stop investing period like there's
nothing that's priced appropriately so
my brain had been chewing on this it
wasn't kind of a random response
that said the lesson of 2000 was you
know things that go this way also go
this way and this specific reason things
clapped in 2000 was the federal reserve
raised interest rates six times from mid
1999 to early 2000 and what that did was
it caused technology stocks to collapse
collapsed by 90 percent so i was like
well guess what if the fed raises
interest rates six times technology
stocks are going to collapse by 90 this
is like a law of physics we had actually
used this slide a version of this slide
which i've actually tweeted recently in
our lp presentation at founders fund the
last two years so we've been internally
talking to our lps saying eventually
interest rates have to go up when
interest rates go up technology stocks
will go down yeah we can talk about why
that is but it is actually inevitable
and so
when the the reason why that specific
timing came to be is
for a long time many people myself
included have been talking about
publicly jack dorsey et cetera that
we've been going through inflation in
the united states um i started tweeting
about inflation in january 2022
and uh oh sorry yeah maybe actually 21
but yeah 21 sorry getting the years
confused
and but everybody was the government the
current administration and their you
know sort of supporters were in denial
about that were inflation and they were
suffering inflation there's all these
excuses it's like transitory blah blah
blah you should see the reaction to my
tweet about we're in real inflation and
everybody's like a transitory like no
it's not transitory that's the stupidest
thing ever um but
basically all the excuses were starting
to decay over the last year and by
october even the transitory people like
ran out of logic to argue that it was
transitory so i was like basically
what's going to happen is eventually
when the excuses go away
the fed and everybody else is going to
realize we have actual inflation when
they have actual inflation the
technology stocks will start going down
and so that's basically what happened so
when one there was one press conference
i think the white house press secretary
basically gave up on the transitory line
i was like okay all hell's gonna break
loose and that was right around then and
that's why i was like okay well you
don't have to discount the probability
that people figure this out anymore so i
don't want to spend too much time on
macro but uh they say inflation's eight
point six percent now the fed when it
was seven percent back in december was
still uh conducting quantitative easing
they hadn't raised interest rates just
what's your general take in terms of uh
maybe incompetence ignorance how do we
get here and then how much confidence do
you put in their ability to uh navigate
a i think they call it a soft landing
now um
euphemistic for a recession like a
moderate recession uh moderate
unemployment moderate session um no
there's an old paper from milton
friedman in 1972 that you all should
read basically bill freeman argued among
many things but this is probably his
number one nobel prize winning
contribution is that
a federal central decision maker whether
the federal reserve or some other
institution will always get this wrong
they will always
raise rates when they should be lowering
them and lower rates when they should be
raising them basically the lag is too
great so that leads to consistent
because you're basically amplifying the
problem by the time you act but then it
makes the problem worse so the best
thing to do is to do nothing in his view
and it's a very well argued paper so
this is a classic illustration of that
but um
right now
i don't know all i can do is go shopping
so this is what i've told several some
of the people here before just go to the
grocery store and if the price of your
groceries going up every week we have
inflation if they start settling and
being stable then you know we're fine
and then when they start going down
again we'll have deflation which is not
necessarily a good thing but in any
event
groceries are still going up as far as i
can tell
the craziest thing to me is uh i don't
know why i did this but one day i went
deep down the rabbit hole of how they
calculated influence oh yeah yeah that's
466 people who are employed by the
bureau of labor statistics and they go
into the grocery store and they're
giving a printout and they make sure
they find the exact campbell soup tomato
with no salt and there's like an 11-page
document to make sure they have the
right one and then they punch it into a
device so yeah so when we were starting
square before we launched we wanted to
build a true inflation tracker so
because we had all these good in
services obviously
sales in real time price adjustments
basically in real time and so when jack
started tweeting about inflation
hyperinflation i was like he's looking
at real data he's not making this stuff
up he's not a backer he's not being a
macro thinker he's actually seeing the
data and so it was so obvious from the
square data that we had real inflation
in early 2021 well it's not just the
price and point of sale stuff there's
also uh payroll data like he kind of has
a full 360 view of the economy to some
degree and i think that it does beg the
question so we have i don't know we can
call like an analog version of price uh
um collection versus even if you look at
apartment.com or zillow open or like all
of these real-time data points and
sometimes 100 million data they don't
use real-time data so here's the funny
there's just a twitter thread about this
this morning so you talk about leasing
the methodology really matters so if you
say what is the rate of inflation on
rental prices you can calculate it two
different ways and you can you'll
immediately see the difference one is
across all leases in the united states
the other is leases signs in the last
three months guess what one is up like
41 and one is up six percent guess which
one actually tells you where you are
i can only imagine
um when you start to think of uh the
geopolitical landscape there's a lot of
blaming of inflation on the putin price
hike and other uh excuses that have been
uh invented recently um but i don't know
if you saw i think putin yesterday or
today gave a speech and in it he
basically said hey this is exactly
what's happening he talked about the
monetary expansion he talked about
the us's sanctions and how that
drastically reduces people's trust in
keeping their
foreign currencies and reserves with the
u.s system
how much do you think about
things outside of the tech industry or
the business industry when it comes to
geopolitics inflation or other things
that could be like macro or external
shocks to the system well i don't think
this is a macro shock this is pretty
simple there's a
let's see there's two only two variables
that lead to inflation you have a
a fairly finite amount of goods produced
and over time it's not finite but at one
point in time at this point in time
today this week maybe next month there's
only a certain amount of variance how
many goods there are that's all the
goods that could be bought by everybody
in the world or everybody in the country
and when the government prints more
money
there's only one thing that can happen
there's more money chasing the same
number of goods guess what the price has
to go up like this is so basic
it's like basically
where you're going with this by the way
i actually think all life kind of works
this way that there's a couple
fundamental principles and once you
understand them the world just makes
common sense it's like you know
newtonian physics and stuff like that
what's another example
um like another example of how this
applies to wrestling
let's see yeah this was another one a
good one i stumped keith for a boy
everyone no it's just like i have so
many of these like it's like simple it's
basic simple rules like i i did tweet
once i was actually pretty popular
surprisingly popular tweet that like the
easiest way to be successful is just
forget all the stupid stuff in the world
if you didn't know anything you'd
probably be more successful i was going
to ask you at the end but i'll ask you
now are you going to put your kids
through traditional school or how do you
think about educating them so that they
don't have to unlearn things later good
question they're 11 months old so
starting to think about it they're not
ready for homeschooling yet although we
are interviewing educators to start like
indoctrinating them i've taught i've
actually taught the little baby boy like
my favorite expression which is no no no
but really good at it i guess how do you
think about the legacy education system
and is it net positive net negative like
do you see
specific things that should be changed
or fixed there that would have a drastic
impact yeah i mean homeschooling has
been the greatest success of policy in
the last 40 years anywhere on the planet
so 40 years ago there's about 78 000 i
think kids that went they were
homeschooled last year there was five
million
that's where the world's going and the
reason why is some of it's ideological
like people that are opposed parents are
opposed to what they're being their kids
are being taught um zoom sort of
unlocked a lot of that exposure because
suddenly you could like watch what your
kids are really taught a lot of parents
are like barfing like oh my god i didn't
realize they were doing that all day
second though is
one size fits all education makes no
sense if you want your kids to be
successful you need to allow them to
grow at their own pace and challenge
them to grow at faster and faster paces
and
a school a traditional school room just
is not organized that way
so keith has no clue that i'm going to
ask him this
i want to do an example of how you
critically think about topics and i
figured i'd find something that was
complex enough uh but also not uh leave
you completely outside like live magic
tricks basically um
gun control has
[Laughter]
started the easy stuff and then build
from there cool well the reason why i
think it's an interesting one to uh kind
of talk through is there's an emotional
element to it right there's obviously
people who get hurt uh die
and that emotional component can make
people mad can make people
sad all this stuff there's also kind of
a constitutional element to it in
people's rights
then there's also a federal level a
state level there's like this individual
responsibility versus dependence on the
government you know pretty simple
problem here so how do you think through
not necessarily what is the answer but
like how do you think through coming to
a conclusion as to where you would stand
on an issue like that yes it's a good
it's a good example um so
one thing i would do is i tend to like
to contrast things either before or
after or in multi-states like so like to
take data from point a and compare it to
point b and you kind of just did this
with kovid which is a popular thing to
do the reason why one of the reasons why
we moved to miami was all the policies
of san francisco made no sense to us
like everything san francisco and
southwest california was doing were
completely irrational we're just like we
just woke up and said we're not wasting
our lives this way and we're moving you
know et cetera so the good news was
miami and florida were an open
laboratory where you could compare
different policies around masks and
vaccination and indoor outdoor weather
all this stuff and so basically just
take that experiment there's a you know
the framework of the constitution sort
of framers of the country basically how
this call like clever phrase turn a
phrase called laboratories of democracy
and that the whole point of having 50
states was that you have 50 different
policies and see what worked and what
didn't work and without that actually
you have one unified policy that you're
running one experiment at a time which
isn't a great way to learn so i always
start that way and there's great places
great books to read like i also like
books i have a li i actually built maybe
the first library in miami um because a
custom built library um i was like none
of the homes here seem to have built-in
libraries i need a built-in library so
it took me six months but i have one um
but so i go back to like books
interesting books what's it what's one
so john on gun control john lott who's i
think still a professor at university
chicago wrote a series of books about
gun control you know there's critics and
debate it debates about the quality you
know the research but it's it's it's a
pretty good start and then you can read
all the critics of different studies and
different chapters if you want to but
it'll give you a good introduction um
and then
the other thing to do is actually there
uh there's a lot of data that you know
sometimes the world is getting a lot
better than people realize there's a
couple there's two really good books
about this but about how the world's
better than people realize and one thing
about gun violence particularly is when
i was growing up the gun violence was
like probably an order magnitude worse
than it is today in the united states
like your chance of being murdered with
a gun was like about 10x spence where
you live in the new york city for
example where i was growing up it was at
least like basically 10x more likely
that you'd be murdered with a gun than
today so to some extent you also have
this like comparison set of like what
problems are you trying to solve what
risks are real what risks are very real
then we have this a little bit with
covet too like if you really cared about
the risks of kovid are you changing
everything else in your life like your
chance at certain ages of dying by
drowning was significantly greater than
your chance of dying by covet your
chance of dying in an auto accident at
certain ages was significantly greater
than a chance of dying by covet but
people didn't stop driving
the joke i think is always um there are
states that want to leave the united
states or if you go to those states they
may talk about it california at one
point somebody proposed to break it up
uh texas i saw an article recently that
there's people who are always talking
about it florida it just happens to be
kind of you know on the edge and people
think it could go underwater or float
away
how do you think about the state
experiment today is that what we need to
put more emphasis on or do you think
that there's actually a healthy balance
between kind of federal government and
state
experiment i think the experimentation
state level is great in education you're
also seeing that um where there's some
ideas here that are going to become
popular there's you're seeing starting
seeing competition now around policy
like city city by city policy like why
are we all moving to miami because the
city here has different policies than
other places and you know as i saw a lot
of people tweeting you know after the
news this morning that citadel's moving
here a lot of people are tweeting like
oh well all these cities are going to
have to really start competing i mean
the framework around city competition is
we're now all your customers and cities
have to compete for our business states
have to compete for our business we're
not you know
basically locked down into some
monopolistic you know tyranny and so
that's going to change everything now at
the city level where everybody tries to
attract business attract know
entrepreneurs attract
high performing people on different
industries
when's the last time you changed your
mind oh all the time
this is underrated i mean i used to be a
silicon valley elitist i was like the
worst defender ever like up until like
two ish years ago or maybe three i
remember internally even um peter would
want to move founders fund outside the
bay area and he moved outside the barrio
2015 i think um and he was always on
this crusade that we needed to get
founders fun outside of the bay area and
i i used to think he was like crazy like
you know like this thinking when he was
making these arguments that's what made
you think he was crazy
that's what made you think he was crazy
yeah well i agreed with most the other
stuff no um
uh like that's what we call a softball i
would only invest in like companies in
silicon valley you know i had maybe left
some ten percent of my portfolio of
investments was outside silicon valley
until 2019 and then obviously i changed
you know pretty radically and the
epiphany coveted obviously magnified the
epiphany but the epiphany was not from
coven it was in february 2020 i met this
founder from germany from brooklyn
um showed up in my office and i didn't
even want to take the meeting honestly
like uh my colleague matias who you know
was constantly trying to
force me to take this damn meeting i
kept trying to cancel it and he's like
no you got to take with me you got to
meet i'm like cancel
take the meeting too anyway i show up
finally
sit down
three minutes into the presentation i
was like oh my god we need to invest and
so i was just like trying to well hold
on i'll come down so i was just like oh
my god oh my god i need to invest and so
i was basically selling the founder on
like working with us the whole time so i
walk out of the meeting and matias like
taps me on the shoulder at the time we
had we'd only worked together for like
about a year we didn't know each other
as well um so he touched my shoulder and
he's like what happened to you
it's like what happened like you know
like you barely wanted to take the
meeting and i was like you just found
the greatest founder in the history of
europe and like we're investing
um and so but that epiphany of like the
sing i i sometimes call him the michael
jordan but this if michael jordan is
sitting in berlin then the epiphany
wants them why the hell do i need to be
just sitting in silicon valley and why
are all the entrepreneurs sitting in
silicon valley because this guy
had never been to silicon valley before
this fundraising trip he had no
connection to silicon valley there was
no side channel of information the new
bank example is a little different
because they went to stanford business
school one worked at sequoia so yes they
built a great and very impressive
company in brazil but they had a lot of
infusion of silicon valley thinking in
people and networks
uh christian a trade republic had zero
he'd learned it all sort of online and
through osmosis and i was like great
well michael jordan's sitting in berlin
then the days of silicon valley are over
i asked for questions online now i'm
taking one of them because it was so
good
when's the last time you were wrong oh
yeah i saw that one uh
well i'm wrong i mean the funny thing
about being a vc is you're wrong all the
time i'm you know like for example
if i do my job really well i'll probably
write 40 of the time
that means 60 of the time i'm wrong
yes but you have told me uh
what is the percentage of founders that
you've met
just tell you just tell the uh i don't
want to ruin it yeah so this is mostly
true
it's mostly true because every day like
as an experiment you can screw it up
but
uh
i've basically
maybe met one founder in person
that i should have invested in that i
didn't
in like 20 years now that's
turned down
a significant number of meetings
but out of the ones that turned into
good companies so keith basically said
to me one time he said uh out of all of
the times that i've met a founder in
person i basically have never missed and
then actually i'm surprised that now
maybe there's one well there's one one
the one's a complicated story i actually
wound up becoming an investor later but
i i missed on the seed which it cost me
100 x
small thing um but i fixed it i realized
that i made a mistake i'm like this is
we need to fix this actually that's
interesting so what made you fix it and
why were you not emotionally tied to
like i missed it i'll just go find the
next early stage company
well
without giving away the company but
maybe it's fine to give away the company
um my mom actually convinced me i was
wrong
this is very true she's like why did you
pass on the company x and i'm like blah
blah blah and she's like no it's amazing
and i'm like
so yeah like uh that that's actually the
story i tell publicly like when when we
announced the financing because some
people knew i had passed earlier um and
just that's true it was true charlie
true unfortunately she's coming to visit
this weekend i'm sure she's gonna remind
me
has mom ever commented on another
investor yes
yeah you want to make her on your
reporter to your investment committee
maybe
she's got a lot of free time right now
sitting in charlottesville virginia
she's got plenty of time
but uh no she she's usually more
conservative that's well that's why it
was so astounding was like i remember
when i joined linkedin she's like
nobody'll ever use that and put their
resumes online yelp like nobody near us
in new jersey you know we'll ever use
that blah blah blah so she's often wrong
but she she did this was striking
counter treating she did call stripe
correctly yeah you're accounting of
trading mom until stripe okay yeah now i
listen to her much better
um the last thing i want to talk about
i'm just going to call it uh kind of
wokism seems to have infiltrated
everywhere and it's not a thing right it
is
a state of mind it's a set of ideas but
everything from uh the way we work the
way that we operate on a daily basis the
things we're allowed to talk about not
allowed to talk about um just so many
things in life how do you
think through that problem right and i
always say that's actually easy okay
just ignore it
i mean if something's on the wrong side
of history and just wrong the best thing
you can do is like refute either ignore
it or refute it or definitely don't let
it affect you so like use an example
you've invested in a company do you and
you start to see that there's a change
in the company by your reaction i know
you've dealt with this
how do you talk with the founder
is it uh immediate identify it and stomp
this out is it a let's coach
how do you just deal with it no i mean
my role as a board member and investor
is
is really to be a a consigliere which is
like if the founder wants to talk about
it founder identifies that this is a
frustrating or challenging issue then we
can talk about it at length and i can
you know point them in different
directions people to talk about who've
dealt with this before
here's like the pros and cons of
different approaches but like it's not
my job to kind of fix it like ever i
have one well i do have one job but two
jobs i have to fix like if i don't like
with found response investing and i have
to fix that and i've actually been a
little slacking on that and then
obviously at open store it's like
ultimately my responsibility all right
we're gonna take questions in one second
um
you
peter max
we can go to the line there's a bunch of
them if you had to sum up uh one thing
when it comes to critical thinking or
independent thought that you all share
what is that thing is it something you
guys read is it a way of thinking is
it's you know something that you can tie
it all back to and say this is something
we did that a lot of other people don't
no i think there's just because all
these people are very different like all
the paypal people that you named and the
ones you didn't name that are you know
very successful
they all have different asymmetric
advantages in life and they figure out
how to leverage them the common
denominator is that they do think for
themselves they have their own views on
the world so two examples there's a
kind of a funny woody paragraph in uh
zero to one that peter talk peter leads
the book with which actually originally
was going to lead the book if he ever
wrote a paypal book but
enough time was going by he basically
gave it up and put it in zero to one
that four of the six co-founders of
paypal built bombs in high school
so i didn't build a bomb in high school
i was way too normal for that but
um
maybe now i would but like back then i
was way too normal way too normal um but
um that shows a certain kind of thinking
now three of the four before you get too
nervous actually grew up in communist
countries so building a bomb was
probably a pretty good idea um but like
only one of them was american um but uh
in any event like
that kind of hiring philosophy led to
people who are kind of iconoclastic and
iconoclastic people do have the tendency
to think for themselves and then they
figure out what areas are they strongest
and what dimensions so max thinks about
things differently than peter does than
reed does than elon does than jerry
stapleman or chad or you know whoever
but they all have figured out how to be
different you can see like you can see
chad on twitter you can see some of his
iconoclastic thinking um sometimes he
likes to make fun of miami he's
eventually he's eventually moving here
whether he knows it or not chad south
beach hurley that's who's gonna be all
right what questions do you guys have
just raise your hand and uh we'll call
on folks
nobody has over here just yell it out
i think sometimes people think that in
the latter is sort of like they're kind
of like america's over right like it's
too bloated
to fail so people can go off
again we're like really concerned about
you know preserving the west building
the country
do you
so the question just in case anyone
didn't hear is uh basically is there
tension between like hard tech varda and
duro et cetera and then more of like the
u.s is screwed let's build a different
like a skate boat basically with crypto
web 3 uh bitcoin etc
so two answers personally in that
founders fund um
we don't back trends we don't invest in
trends we invest in people so founder
you know if you read the
technology manifesto the founders fund
published probably in 2014
we basically have no one founders so the
right founder we find the right founder
for the right problem and we'll give the
money so we funded varda anderl funded
there's crypto companies we funded we
bought bitcoin directly when that was
appropriate um so fundamentally we just
want to find the right founder tackling
the right problem not try to you know
sort of predict the future but is there
tension i mean ultimately there's people
probably better suited to solve
different types of problems too i'm not
sure i'd be the best biotech founder um
but i could probably learn parts of it
like for example there is a heavy biz
dev component distribution component
that i can learn there's some legal in
like fda so i could learn parts and
contribute but i probably am not
designing molecules very well
and please don't adjust these molecules
if i design them
secondly
i i also think the the best thing about
technology is you get to write the
future so you can believe that america's
in decline and say you know what i'm
going to wake up and do something about
it like think farda and delian um is
actually like america is in decline we
need to do something about it and earl
like america's vulnerable we're going to
do something about it so like technology
is kind of this magic wand that you get
to shape the future you pick it up it's
like learning to code it's kind of this
magic wand you want to rearrange the
world and you kind of walk through the
world and you kind of wave your wand
let's do uh two or three more who else
got a
question why does anybody over 35 years
old believe it
why does anyone over the age of 35
believe in web 3
i planted him
i don't know i guess chris dixon's over
35 so we should probably ask him um he's
way over 35 actually uh so um i don't
know i'm not one of the web 3 proponents
i would invest in a web 3 company if i
believe the founder was tackling a
specific problem
that he or she had insight into and i
have you know funded i guess two
companies that arguably could be web
three-ish but they don't brand
themselves well one definitely doesn't
brand itself it's royal it's reinventing
the music industry just happens to use
some components but it's really
reinventing the music industry for the
future not reinventing crypto the other
one is a more web30 company but it was
the specific founder had insights into a
very unique problem
it's pretty slim chance that's really
going
to
so the question is about nfts uh being
built on top of ethereum being highly
dependent on ethereum and a lot of the
internet history would suggest that it
might not be around 20 years
well i think the macro point behind an
ft makes sense which is
people are going to have concentric
circles of people professionally and
socially that they care about in their
lives that are more virtual or more
digital
than real world like i.e people are
going to manage relationships in the
real world differently than they manage
relationships so like when i go out i
you know care about what sneakers i wear
what brand a shirt i'm wearing you know
to have an apple watch versus like a
traditional watch
people are going to encounter more and
more people online
and nfts of different types or way of
self-expression self-expression is
incredibly important and is there are
there going to be unique ways to express
yourself online absolutely and so what
would you purchase online to express
yourself that's the open question for
entrepreneurs and but it's not that's
not going away that's a human emotion
back to shakespeare
and i think the other piece of this is
just uh
the underlying technology almost doesn't
matter right if i ask you guys what is
the tech stack of google if you're not
an engineer who worked at google most of
you don't know right and so i think at
some point it's just like can people buy
what they want and if it works then it
works what can you transition it too
right i mean like most almost every
successful company i've ever invested in
or been involved in has recoded itself
almost from scratch that's scra you know
from scratch at some point if you have
enough traction you'll reinvent like
square started believe it or not i hate
to give this away but like
on ruby on rails
another very famous site started in php
like you really don't want to worry
about that stuff too much
well you'll just have a different
generation of like
that's oh that's definitely true but
like do people
but like do people still collect the
same baseball cards that they used to
some extent mickey mantle's still
valuable but like the values of
different people change over time too
all right we're gonna take one more
question but uh
quickly what are your thoughts on
bitcoin specifically not the other stuff
have you changed your mind at all
so i had two concepts around bitcoin and
they're they're kind of directionally
correct but not perfectly correct i
don't know that anybody's been perfectly
correct to bitcoin now for a while i was
while there was people claiming to be
perfectly correct with their bitcoin
predictions there's actually i'm not
sure anybody who's really got it right
so
it's hard when things go up hundreds of
percent and down 80 percent yeah
try calling both of those um
to the day um
uh but in any event um i had two
concepts around bitcoin so you know in
some ways as enthusiastic when it first
started because
the original t-shirts at paypal those of
you reading the paypal book will know
this you know we are t-shirts i still
have some at home um the the world you
know the world currency whatever so the
vision of paypal originally was to try
to do this and one of the reasons i was
somewhat dubious about the coin is i
remember how damn hard many pieces of
that were building the new world
currency
were
but the first thing that occurred to me
in 2013 when i started to think about
this like professionally because i
didn't become a vc until 2013 was
bitcoin adoption should be inversely
correlated with the rule of law so in
countries that have a predictable rural
law there should be less adoption to on
a per capita basis or whatever or per gm
gdp or something some metric than in
countries that have a predictable rule
and you can even argue that kind of
happened in the united states like
according to some people after trump got
elected we had less rule of law here and
you do see bitcoin actually appreciating
after the election of trump but
the the number two point that's probably
more live and relevant is
i believe that bitcoin was a speculative
asset
in that eventually
if you could stitch people like to
speculate people speculate on stocks
obviously people will speculate on nfl
games like speculation is a really big
business in the united states if you
could get everybody to adopt a platform
on a speculative basis could someone
build an application layer on top of the
network or the nodes that were built on
speculation in power some fundamental
utilitarian thing that was not
speculation absolutely so i started
saying this as early as 2015 publicly
then you know basically no one's really
built that application layer on top but
there's a lot of nodes that were built
in this speculative error now with
prices going down in other let's say in
equities going down unless people have
less dollars available for speculation
you may have to build on top of the
nodes that are already you know sort of
plugged in but that's like 80 million
folks i mean this is uh if you read um
what is it power law i think they talk
about a lot of speculation a lot of
capital goes in you basically build the
infrastructure and then eventually do it
last question no pressure
so how do you protect
the critical thinking that
the question is science started to
become very political but a huge piece
of science is collaboration especially
sometimes across borders but if it gets
politicized how does a scientist in
america and a scientist in china work
together if there's this political
divide
i think that's a choice
that scientists scientists and quotes
made
most scientists in history that you
remember the names of were incredibly
controversial in their own times and so
i think there's a certain character to
the scientists to come up with the most
important ideas and then eventually
bring the world with them it's not the
other way around like how do i dumb down
my ideas to be approachable to everybody
that's it all right everyone i hope that
you guys enjoyed this thank you so much
for your time
real quick constantine thank you very
much
i think we have this place uh for like
another
hour or so hour and a half so enjoy
there's drinks upstairs there's drinks
downstairs if you need a lawyer
constantine's right there go harass the
[ __ ] out of them uh at reed smith
[Laughter]
yeah yeah one lawyer for the whole room
all right thank you guys